>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Edward Widmer: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming to LJ-119
in the Library of Congress
and the John W. Kluge Center.
It's a great pleasure to
welcome our speaker today.
Before we start the
program I want to ask you
to take a moment to
silence your devices.
We'll also be filming this program,
so think about a good
question before you ask it.
Our lecture today is
sponsored by the Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
We bring together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to distill wisdom from the Library's
rich holdings and to interact
with Congress and the public.
And we find our talented
writers and scholars
from around the world
in a myriad of ways.
We have many scholars in place.
But in today's instance it was a
really nice act of serendipity.
Our speaker was speaking
in Atlanta at a meeting
of the American Library Association.
And our new librarian, Dr. Carla
Hayden, was in the audience and was
so riveted by our speaker
that she said,
"I've got a place for
you to give a talk."
And that was the Kluge
Center a few months later.
I believe it was a Martin
Luther King Day speech.
So we're so happy to
have our speaker.
Our speaker is Dr. Daina Berry, who
an associate professor of history
and African and diaspora studies
and the Oliver H. Radkey fellow
in American history at the
University of Texas at Austin.
She's a prolific author.
She's the author of Swing the
Sickle for the Harvest is Ripe:
Gender and Slavery in
Antebellum Georgia.
She's an award-winning editor
of Enslaved Women in America:
An Encyclopedia and Slavery
and Freedom in Savannah.
She has recently published a book
she will be talking about today.
And I want to note it was published
in one of my favorite presses
in the United States, the Beacon
Press, which is true to its name,
a beacon of liberal -- it used
to be liberal Protestant writing
and now I think we can
just call it liberalism.
But it's a wonderful
press in Boston.
And the book is The Price
for their Pound of Flesh:
The Value of the Enslaved
from the Womb to the Grave
in the Building of a Nation.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Daina Berry.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Thank you
so much for your introduction,
and I want to thank you and your
staff for allowing me to come
and speak about my work here.
It's an honor to be here,
and I was very happy
when Dr. Hayden extended
the invitation.
What I'd like to do is to talk
a little bit about this project
that I've been working on for ten
years, and to talk a little bit
about some of the motivations
behind the research,
and then share a little bit
of reading from parts of it.
And I also want to give time
for Q&A because oftentimes
when I've presented since January,
I've had a lot of really interesting
and very lively discussions
about the subject matter.
Because this is the
history of the enslaved.
And I said that during the writing
process that I really learned more
about myself than I did about the
people that I was writing about
and that I was more a
scholar of the enslaved
than I am a scholar of slavery.
And that's something
that I've learned:
The slavery is the institution
that houses the people
that I'm interested
in writing about.
And so I wanted to begin with just
a quick overview about the book
and about the project,
and then I'm going to talk
about a couple sections from there.
The book is structured around
six different chapters.
And it came out of -- it
grew out of my first book.
It was supposed to be chapter
six of Swing the Sickle,
and the editors thought that
this discussion of slave prices
and slave people's values
just didn't fit with the rest
of what was in the manuscript.
And they said, "You know, that
would be a great separate study."
And when I had written
that particular chapter --
so I've been working on this stuff a
little bit longer than the ten years
because this was part of that
first book project that I did --
I found evidence of enslaved values,
monetary values on their bodies.
And I found that women were
priced higher during their
child-bearing years.
And I wanted to know why I had not
seen that in historical literature,
why I had not seen that outside of
some conversations women were sort
of put as secondary but outside
the conversations that were
in the slave price
literature as well.
And so I wanted to know if
this was a national trend.
I wanted to know, you know, for
all these years between the ages
of let's say 15 to 30
were women priced higher?
And that's sort of what
started me off on this.
And I was basically
collecting a database
of enslaved people's values --
the name, their age, their sex,
their prices, and so forth.
And some of these values come
in the form of appraisals,
which are the annual appraisals
that were done every year to figure
out the projections of how much they
would be over the course of a year
or over the course
of their lifetime.
And some of them also came
in the form of market sales.
And market sales represent the
highest value that a person has.
It's the price that they
command in the auction block.
So this one little
chapter that I had written
for a different book
became its own study
when I started doing
the research and learned
that women were not priced higher
than men and that there was just
that group of plantations
that I was looking
at were actually the anomaly.
They were the outlier.
And that for across the board --
and I'll show you a slide in a
few minutes of the numbers --
men were priced higher than
women across the board.
And so you'll see a
little bit of this.
And I'll show you my
influences where some
of you may know Stanley Engerman,
he's an economic historian,
co-author of Time on the
Cross with Robert Fogel.
He saw me give a talk at Duke when
I was doing the research for this,
when I was still thinking
that women were priced higher.
And he came up to me
afterwards and said, "You know,
I think I have something
that might be useful to you.
Do you have time to
come to Rochester?"
I said, "Sure, why not?"
And I went up there with a
graduate student and my family
and literally left
with eight boxes --
or seven boxes of archival
data that they had collected
from Time on the Cross.
So this was, like, one of the most
generous academic donations somebody
could ever had.
And it totally catapulted my
study in terms of the number
of data points that I had.
But one of the things that I've
wanted to do with this book was
to not just make people dots on
graphs and lines on charts, positive
and negative signs, I wanted to
show their humanity and I wanted
to focus on their humanity.
And I wanted to find a way to
tell their story as a commodity
but as a commodity that's also
a person and a human being,
similar to what Walter
Johnson did in Soul by Soul.
And one of the ways I did this was
to center the voices of the enslaved
and to allow them to
tell these stories
about how they understood themselves
as human beings and as products.
And I'll talk a little bit
about that in a few minutes.
So just the data, this is what a
lot of people are interested in.
I only really have it at
the tops of each chapter.
I ended up with about 80,000
individual slave values,
as I mentioned, appraisal
and market sales.
Some of this came from insurance
records were people were ensuring
their enslaved people from as young
as age nine to as old as age 89
or 90, life insurance policies so
that if the enslaved person passed,
they could then purchase
another laborer with the money
that they had given in with
the premium and so forth.
So that's the dataset.
I think by the time I
cleaned up everything
and made sure there was not
any overlap between the Fogel
and Engerman data and my own data,
I think I ended up with about 55,000
or 56,000 cases that are
used throughout the book.
And each chapter uses about 10,000
to 12,000 to make up the averages.
And this is what I came up with.
This is what I found.
This is a slide -- I realize when
I've been talking about my book,
I've been sharing the
stories of the enslaved,
which is the most important part
for me personally, but I realized
that a lot of people wanted to
know, well, what were the numbers?
So what you have here is this
is based on each chapter.
And I show you the age ranges.
They're not just typical
ten-year age increments.
The first number with the dollar
sign in the column is the value
at that time, it's
converted into 1860 dollars.
And then the number in parentheses
is what it is in 2014 money, okay?
And I used the lowest
income value translators.
So these numbers are actually
a lot larger depending
on which chart you
want to use through --
Economic History Net is where
I went and got those figures.
So but the average enslaved
person was about $10,000
to $15,000 in today's money.
If you think about that, you think
about it in terms of, you know,
the number of enslaved people
folks owned, that's a lot of money.
And a lot of these people had
large plantations, 300 people.
They sometimes had more
money in human bodies
and human chattel than
they did the land.
So that's something to keep in mind.
I can come back to this slide
later during the Q&A if you like.
This is just an example of a bill of
sale, just one sample of the types
of records that I used
to characterize
and find this information.
But one of the things
as I mentioned,
this here is from the
eve of the Civil War.
So it's probably, you know,
in Confederate dollars.
This is an inflated price.
This is probably not --
this particular value
has not been inverted.
And the advertisement here
talks about a 32-year-old male,
but they refer to him as a boy.
They have in this particular
ad his height, his complexion,
and they mention stuff about his
skill, that he was a brick mason.
So just this little slip of paper.
I don't even know how
many characters it is.
It's probably the same
as a contemporary tweet
or a little bit longer --
has a lot of information
about an enslaved person.
And those are the people to whom
which I wrote this
book for and about.
So switching to the structure,
I wanted to read a little bit
from how I looked at how enslaved
people understood and learned
to understand that they
were treated as commodities
and how they responded to that.
Because my other question that
was driving this study was:
What did the enslaved people
think; what did they feel;
how did they respond; how did
they react; what did they know
about their values; did
they care; were they happy
to have high values or low values?
And I will read briefly.
In 1854 Rachel, an infant girl,
was placed on the auction block.
Although she was wrapped
in a coverlet
and she was asleep,
her face was exposed.
An enslaved man had
delivered her to the auction
on the instructions of his enslaver.
Rachel was about a year
old and she was for sale.
As the enslaved man sat on the
courthouse steps with Rachel,
waiting for the noon
hour, the time and place
of many public auctions,
one wonders how he felt.
Was it excruciating for him to
carry out his enslaver's demand
and bring little Rachel
to the market?
Or was he unmoved?
What kind of exchange had
he had with her parents?
Did he feel partially responsible
for what was about to take place?
Imagine trying to keep the baby
calm after she was separated
from her mother and then
handing her over to the sheriff
at the start of the auction.
While the enslaved man sat
holding Rachel in his arms,
the Reverend Nehemiah
Adams, a visitor from Boston
on a three-month tour of the South,
approached him to ask
a few questions.
Adams was startled to see an
enslaved man holding an infant.
"Is the child sick?"
Adams asked.
Responding with deference,
the man replied, "No, Master.
She is going to be sold."
Puzzled, Adams inquired
about the child's mother,
to which the man answered
that she was quote, "At home."
The minister's mind was filled with
questions, but most importantly,
he worried about Rachel's mother.
How did she feel?
How much did she miss her child?
Was the infant taken
openly or in private?
Who did this?
By now Rachel was weeping
and refusing to be comforted.
This was too much for Adams,
who chose not to stay
and witness the sale.
Later he learned that Rachel
had been sold for $140.
Imagine her confusion as
she looked at the group
of potential buyers gazing at her,
evaluating her earning potential.
How did Rachel even begin
to process what occurred?
Her inconsolable crying is one
clue, but she was too young
to express her feelings
in any other way.
So I open with infancy because
when I was doing this research,
I've said this before, I had
columns in my dataset of years old.
And I had to create a
column for months old
when I found an 8-month-old
baby for sale.
And then I had to create a column
when I found a 6-week-old baby
in the market with
no parent for sale.
And then when I found a 3-day-old
baby, I actually had to take a break
from the research for about
a week because it moved me
in a way I wasn't expecting.
I wasn't expecting to see it.
And I didn't even know how
to process it at the time.
I thought -- I can't imagine
and I can't even imagine it
from this particular
child's perspective.
But I wanted to think about
ways for teaching my students
and for teaching the general public
to whom this book is also written
of how do we understand how
enslaved people were commodified?
How do we understand they were
treated as a person with a price,
as Walter Johnson refers to it?
And how did they make sense of this?
So moving ahead, there's a time
period where enslaved children start
to transition into
understanding what's happening.
Not only are they learned
and raised to know
that they're also commodities
because their parents teach them
that or the people that
are caring for them do,
so they're living in a dual world.
Sort of like W.E.B. Du Bois talks
about in the double consciousness.
So they're already being
raised in that space.
But this often happens
around five or six,
that they recognize there's
something different about themselves
and about the white
children that they're around.
"Many a man 50 years old had
not seen what I had before my
20th year."
These are the words of Jordan H.
Banks, who was born into slavery,
sold three times, escaped twice,
and ultimately reached freedom.
His early years were
pleasant compared to those
as he matured into adulthood.
In his narrative which was published
in 1861, we learn many things
about the value of the enslaved
and the ways enslavers, traders,
and medical doctors
trafficked human chattel
from birth to death and beyond.
Banks lived on a Virginia
plantation with his parents
and 16 siblings, which
is pretty unusual.
His mother served as a cook,
his father was the head man,
and the family was intact.
As a young child, he played with
his enslaver's son, Alexander,
who was just about a year older.
But by age five Banks
began to realize that he
and Alex were different when
his playmate began beating him.
Banks fought back because
his father warned him
that had he not responded, he
would suffer continued beatings.
Embracing this spirit,
Banks kept track
of how many whippings he owed Alex
and he returned them blow for blow.
Even in childhood, Banks' actions
showed a nascent understanding
of what I call his soul value, which
was separate from his enslaver.
As he processed the distinctions
between himself and his nemesis,
Banks experienced another epiphany.
Alex attended school while
he was sent to quote,
"Scare crows in the fields."
In his words, the dreary days
of boyhood began in the fields.
Now, this moment during enslaved
childhood served as a turning point
in Banks' life and the understanding
of the reality of their condition.
Historian Wilma King calls this the
quantum leap into the world of work.
And as they aged, enslaved
youth and young adults learned
and intimately understood
their place in the world.
Banks' maturation solidified his
understanding of enslavement,
especially during three
pivotal events
of his youth and early adulthood.
The first was the sale
of his two sisters,
the second was the nearly-fatal
beating of his mother,
and the third was the slow
death of his enslaver.
Of the latter, Banks
remarked, "I saw him in life.
I saw him in death.
But he left me in chains."
So to me this just is a way
to understand how enslaved
people are starting
to recognize what it
means to be a commodity,
to recognize that there's
something different about themselves
than their white playmates
to whom they had been playing
with for most of their lives.
And they also start paying
attention to their values.
There was a slave, a young woman
named Merlida [assumed spelling]
who talks about how she was put on
the auction block, and she remembers
that they put her up for $600.
And her mistress came and
said, "No, you can't sell her,"
and she was crying because she
didn't want her owner to sell her.
And they took her down
off the block.
And she says, "Although I wasn't
sold that day, I remember my price."
And this interview was taken 80
years later, but she remembers
on that day exactly
how much she was worth
and that her owner didn't think
that that was the right time
or value to sell Merlida.
And so this even, regardless of what
other kind of memories they have,
there are vivid memories of pricing.
And they talk about this
throughout their work.
And one of the things that I
found difficult was that I felt
like scholars spent most of their
time focusing on male prices,
particularly inflated
males in their prime years
and very few people looked
at how women were valued.
But I also felt that they
were missing how enslaved
people survived.
And there's a lot of people that
have written about resistance
and so forth, but I
kept thinking to myself,
"How did 4 million
people end up in 1865
to have survived this institution?
You know, what did they turn to?"
They weren't all socially dead, they
weren't all in a melancholy state.
They might have experienced
depression --
what we're calling depression today.
They might have experienced
grief and sadness,
but how did they survive?
And there had to be something.
And one of the things I came up
with was that they had a notion
of a value that could
not be commodified.
And I'll share what that is.
The pubescent years were terrifying.
Not only were their bodies
changing, but this was also a time
when enslaved children
experienced a separation
that they had feared
all of their lives.
Daughters and sons were taken from
their parents as the external value
of their bodies increased.
Market scenes from childhood
now made sense and haunted them
for the rest of their lives.
At this stage in their
maturation they knew full well
that others claimed
ownership of them
and that sexual assault
came at any age.
However, their parents, if present,
as well as other kin reminded them
of a value that enslavers and
traders could not commodify:
The spiritual value of
their immortal souls.
Soul values is my term
for such valuation.
And it often escapes calculation
and developed during these years.
Soul values are enriched through
an inner spiritual centering
that facilitated survival and they
were reinforced by loved ones.
Sometimes this internal value
appeared as a spirit, a voice,
a vision, a whisper, a premonition,
a sermon, a ancestor, a god.
It came in public and private
settings and occasionally described
as a personal message from a
higher being or a heaviness
in the core of their bodies.
"My soul began singing," one
enslaved person recalled,
"and I was told that I was
one of the elected children."
This telling, this uplifting,
this singing of a fearful thrill
of things unknown but longed
for still made the enslaved
feel free during captivity.
Freedom of the soul
matured in puberty.
And so it's really at this stage
when they're in their teen years
and going into puberty when girls
are going through their cycles
and now their values are increasing
because they can give birth
to additional laborers
where planters don't have
to then purchase them because
their value of the enslaved,
the status of the slave
is defined by the mother.
So if your mother was
enslaved and you gave birth,
those children were
also enslaved as well.
So this is why during those
eight plantations that I found
in Swing the Sickel that I found
women were priced higher, I thought,
"Well, this has got to be the case
across the whole country, right,
in terms of other enslaved
communities?"
And the only thing I
can say for that --
because I've been trying to figure
out why that was the case --
is that most of those plantations
were on one island community,
St. Simon's Island, Georgia.
They were, like, 12 plantations
there total, but eight of them
where the female plantation
mistress was serving as a manager
because either their husbands were
deceased, they had gone off to war,
they had gone on political
leave, and so forth.
So some of these plantations
were managed by women
and perhaps that's why
their values were there.
I don't know.
But that's one of the things that I
think about and one of the solutions
that I think would make sense.
So now shifting to how
enslaved people responded
and what do they know
about their values,
we know that they were
given a rating system
where they were either a full
hand, three-quarters hand,
half hand, one-quarter hand.
A full hand was A1 prime, which
was someone between the ages of 18
and 30 years of age who
could do certain amount
of work in a given day.
And most other enslaved laborers
were sort of judged based
on that person but on
a decreasing scale.
And that value, that rate was
often correlated with their prices.
So if they kept rates.
Not all plantation owners kept
track of the rating system,
but when they did, we're finding
direct connections with the values.
And so one of the things
that you hear when you look
at the auction records and you hear
bid callers and you read the text
from bid callers and they'll say,
"This is a first-rate person,
there's a first-rate bargain,
he's A1 prime, he's strong;
or she's got -- look at her arms,
look at her healthy babies,"
when they're trying to bid them off.
And here's what enslaved
people say about first rate.
Bid caller and criers shouted
out the values of enslaved people
as prime, first-rate, and A1.
But from freedom in Canada, Benjamin
Miller explained what he thought
first-rate meant.
Before his escape in North Carolina,
his North Carolinian enslaver
had trusted him to travel to
and from the market, running
errands and to do favors.
Sometimes his enslaver gave
him small amounts of money.
He says quote, "But
I was still a slave."
On one occasion, Miller said he was
trying to purchase himself for $450
and neighbors told his enslaver
that that was too low of a value
and that he needed to increase it.
So his enslaver said,
"You can purchase yourself
if you give me $800."
All right?
And at this point, he felt
like that was too much
and he didn't have
the money, obviously.
So when he heard that
he had raised the price,
Miller was unwilling to pay for it.
Instead, he fled without paying
and made his way to Canada.
Reflecting on this pivotal event,
Miller discussed what it
meant to be first-rate.
"I have done first-rate
here," he says from Canada,
"I will tell you what
I call first-rate.
I say first-rate from the fact
that we have to row against wind
and tide when we get here.
And being brought up illiterate,
I consider that if we live
and keep our families well-fed and
clad, we have done first-rate."
So this is, like, the first
time where we're thinking about,
you know, what did enslaved
people think, what did they know
about their values, how
do we make sense of this?
And shifting just a
little bit further
to two other slaves I'll just tell
you about quickly, and then I wanted
to end with an aspect
of this research
that took me on a three-year detour.
And it's really where I think I had
to just decide I was going to stop.
And it's where I hope to
pick up from here forward.
But Mingo was an enslaved man who
I write about, and I found a poem
of his that was written on
the beam of a prison wall.
And he had ran away when his family
and he were separated
from one other.
And he didn't want to live
without his wife and his children.
And apparently he had been
writing poems all his life.
And he wrote this poem and he's
thinking about this is his last life
on earth and he probably
won't see his family again.
And he wanted to leave
something for them
to think about if they ever knew.
But this was just his way of sort
of addressing his enslavement.
I'm not going to read
the whole poem,
but I'll just read what
he would say to his wife.
"Dear wife, they cannot sell the
rose of love that in my bosom glows.
Remember as your tears may start,
they cannot sell thy immortal part."
And so for me, Mingo recognized
that there was a place in him,
in his wife, and in their bodies
and their souls and their spirits
that could not be commodified,
that could not be sold.
And I feel like he's trying
to leave that message for her.
Isaac is another enslaved man
that I think out of everybody
in the whole book --
he's in chapter five --
really exemplifies soul value.
He was caught for planning
an insurrection.
It was a conspiracy because
somebody found out about it.
And they captured him, put him in
jail, and they were trying to find
out who else was involved in this.
And they kept asking him
questions, you know, like --
and he said, "I'm the one.
Take me. I'm the one.
There's nobody else."
And they said, "Well, there's got
to be other people
that were doing this."
He's like, "No, take me.
I'm the one.
I'm the man.
I'll live with the consequences."
And so that night his minister,
who he was very close to,
came to visit him in jail.
And they had a four-hour
conversation.
And they talked, they laughed,
they cried, they prayed together.
And we have this evidence
from a newspaper writer
who was there at the jail.
This is how I know
the story about Isaac.
And the minister was that
tears because the minister felt
like he was the guilty one.
He said, "I feel like
I'm the guilty one.
I feel like I'm the hypocrite."
And he said this is a noble man.
You know? And when he asked him,
he said, "Well, don't you love us?
Why would you plan
this rebellion, Isaac?
I don't understand."
And Isaac says, "I love
you and I love master.
I love my master, I love
my mistress," he said,
"But I will kill you, too,
first if I have to," he said,
"Because I want to be free.
And I believe that God is a god
of the black and the white,"
this is the language he uses, "and
that I'm not supposed to be captive.
I'm not supposed to
be held captive."
And so the next day after they
finished praying and crying,
it was the day of his execution.
He was there and he was
getting ready to be hung.
And he was there and there
were other men there.
There were four or
five other men present.
And one of them was his
brother, Isaac's brother.
And they said, "Do you
have any final words?"
A rope is around his neck,
he's standing at the gallows.
They're about to put the latch
to let the floor underneath him
and he says, "I have no other words,
except for if you just let me die,
you know, I will die a noble death."
And he said -- and he looked at
the other men, he said, "Comrades,
be men and die like men."
He jumped before they
could pull the latch,
lifted up his feet,
and hung himself.
And although it's like from
our perspective it might seem
like suicide, it's his way of
expressing his own power in deciding
when he's going to die, in deciding
when his life is going to end.
For so long his life was
controlled by other people.
He did not tell whoever
else was involved.
And as soon as that happened,
the other four or five men
that were there did
the exact same thing.
And so they all took their lives
without letting somebody else pull
the latch from under their feet.
And I think that is one of the
strongest evidence of soul value
for me out of all the cases
that I tell in this story.
And so I thought that
I would end the book
and when I was writing it
thought that the book would end
with them reflecting on life and
life after death or life at death.
Because some of them,
death meant freedom.
Elizabeth Keckley says --
thinking about death she says,
"At the grave at least we should be
permitted to lay our burdens down,
that a new world, a world of
brightness may open to us.
The light that is denied us
here should grow into a flood
of effulgence beyond the dark,
mysterious shadows of death."
So they're looking towards death
as a place, a respite place, right?
And one of the descendants of Nat
Turner, Lucy Turner also speaks
of death, and she says, "Sometimes
there is a victory in the grave,
which leads to a bright eternal
heaven where faith, hope, charity,
love, and justice shall last
forever without ceasing."
And this is where I was thinking
that I was going to end the book.
And I then discovered
that once their bodies --
once they died, there was
an illegal traffic and trade
in their cadavers were planters
were then selling their bodies
to medical schools for
anatomical research.
And so that the commodification
extended beyond the grave,
beyond their natural lives.
And I just want to show
you a few slides of that.
This is what I call the
domestic cadaver trade
where enslaved people were put
sometimes -- and I should say this,
it's not just enslaved people.
Any unclaimed bodies, white,
black, any nationality,
whether they were unclaimed,
whether they were
from an alms house,
a jail, a hospital.
There was a certain period that
if the body wasn't claimed,
then they could be turned over
to medical schools for research.
All right?
Now, I was interested in those
that were of the formerly enslaved,
and I was trying to find, you
know, where are these bodies?
I don't know whether or not all of
them were, but I did find a number
and numbers of black bodies
on dissection room tables
and in the records of
these medical schools.
And this is the three-year
detour I took.
So one of the things that they
did, they had these resurrect men,
grave robbers exhume
bodies out of graves
and they would put
them in bags like this.
Or they would put them -- I thought
I had the whiskey one there, next --
this is an outdoor dissection
that took place at the University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
It's a disturbing image.
And you'll see the black
gentleman in the front sitting
on the pail is the janitor or
probably the resurrection man.
This picture was taken
after slavery.
But one of the things
I found was most
of the medical schools had
African-American janitors,
and the janitor's role was to
procure bodies for dissection.
So there were African-American men
that were owned by universities --
we're learning a lot about
slavery in universities now;
there will be a watershed of studies
in the next few years coming --
but they were owned
by the university,
and the university paid them to go
get bodies and get fresh subjects
for dissection is the
language they used.
These men were resurrection men.
At the top of the screen you'll
see the very top of the picture --
I don't know if you can see --
the very top here is an
African-American man whose name is
Grandison Harris, he worked for
the Medical College of Georgia.
And he worked there
for a number of years.
Seven faculty members owned
one-seventh of his body.
So they actually used his body as --
you know, if you left the college,
you could then sell your
one-seventh share of Grandison.
But he was property
of the university.
And these are the whiskey
casks that was the other --
they were taking them
long distances.
If they were traveling over state
lines, they would hide them.
They would sometimes ship them.
After 1842, they'd put them on
the railroad industry as well
after railroads were built.
And I found that a lot of the routes
for the domestic cadaver
trade were the same routes
as the domestic slave trade,
which I think is really ironic.
So even on ships, in the bellies
of these ships, or even steamboats
where enslaved were kept, there
were also deceased enslaved people
in casks being sent to medical
schools for anatomical research.
This is a picture of Chris
Baker at the Medical College
of Virginia, which is VCU today.
He was one of the major
resurrection men who was born there.
His father was in the
business before that.
So we know that this was going on
as early as the 1820's, 1830's.
And it wasn't until the
1880's in most states
that they had anatomical acts
where they could then try
to regulate this traffic.
This is another picture from 1896.
This is from Murder in Virginia,
a book by Suzanne Lebsock.
And she talks about Chris Baker here
because there was a murder case.
And there was a dispute about
who was going to have the body;
was the family going to
have the body to bury
or was the medical school
going to have the body?
So there was this fight
over the body.
And you see Chris Baker
even after slavery
in 1896 is still the go-to
person for transporting bodies.
And after I finished the book, I
found a notice about Chris' funeral.
And one of the things
that I'm working
on now is a new book
called Blood Ties.
And the it's history of these
resurrection men and their offspring
because a lot of them were two
or three generations deep
working at these institutions.
And I'm trying to understand
what their lives were like
and how they grew up
to learn this business.
But they had elaborate funerals for
them because they were well-liked
and they were well-respected
among the medical community.
But a lot of the people whose bodies
that they traded never
had a proper burial.
And so I thought that was a
really interesting contrast.
And they paid to go to
these anatomy lectures.
So there was money
generated out of the lectures.
There was money for the bodies.
There was money to pay
the faculty members.
These are just some anatomy
admission lecture tickets.
And in 1882, these were all from a
scrapbook from the medical college
in Philadelphia, College
of Physicians.
This is just them writing out
the story of body snatching.
I had to start in the 1890's
and move my way back
to find this history.
And I knew it would be like
a needle in a haystack.
Michael Sappol from the National
Library of Medicine talked about it
in A Traffic of Dead Bodies.
Margaret Washington talked
about this particular trade
briefly in Medical Apartheid.
And Todd Savitt also did write about
this in Medicine and Slavery.
And so I wanted to look for
that needle in a haystack
and spent three years in medical
libraries, medical schools looking
at their admissions books,
looking at their account records
and lecture notes and found
a number of quote unquote
"Negro subjects" for
dissection there.
Stephen Kinney out of Liverpool is
also doing work on this as well.
He's looking at medical museums.
So there's going to be more
work coming out in this area.
And this is just a draft of
the Pennsylvania Anatomy Act,
which then says, you know,
there's regulation on who gets
to have these bodies and how they're
equally distributed amongst the
medical colleges.
This is just some more
documents on that.
The post-Anatomy Act,
they have the list.
This is before it becomes
more institutionalized,
and then it becomes records
of an anatomical review board.
And Dr. [inaudible] at UVA,
who's here, is doing work on this
from the 20th century forward, late
19th century through, like, 1930's.
And so she's looking at these
particular records as well.
So you'll see more
work in this area.
And I wanted to just close with this
fact that the bodies that were found
from the Medical College of
Georgia where Grandison Harris was
for several years serving as the
chief body snatcher or janitor,
they were finally laid
to rest in 1998.
So this history's a lot closer
to us than people realize.
People always want to say,
"Oh, slavery was so far away."
But these bodies were just
buried not too long ago.
The Medical College of Virginia
or VCU has also uncovered a number
of bodies that were in a well
that we believe were the bodies
that Chris Baker had helped exhume.
And they're in debates now about
what kind of ceremony they want
to have to honor those that were
dishonored in a previous lifetime.
And they were buried
here in unmarked grave.
Their remains were there.
They put in a 2,500-pound vault
so that no one would tamper them.
And the last sentence here says,
"May they rest in external peace."
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
So I have this here
because I did a piece
in the Times last year
about this body trade.
And I started getting
emails like this
where people were sending me facts
that there are catalog
entries for skulls today.
Nat Turner's skull was recently
turned over to the family.
They're doing forensic testing
on it right now to find out,
and the family wants to do
a particular burial for him.
So this is not a history that's old.
It's still here.
This is a newspaper ad about
the bones and the remains
from Virginia Commonwealth
University that I mentioned.
So we are still dealing with
this history, and I would love
to have conversation about
anything I've talked about,
including the contemporary
ramifications
of this history as well.
And there's a microphone
circulating for Q&A.
Over here, yeah.
>> Thank you so much for this.
I actually was very curious to
know more about the cadaver trade
and maybe the kind of
anthropological element of it
in terms of I know that up until
probably only the last five decades
or so there was a lot of kind of
hair-splitting between the idea
of people of different races
being different species.
So as these cadavers are being
brought in and being tested
and being examined, are
they kind of feeding some
of those very racist ideas,
species-ist ideas or are they looked
at as, "Well, hey, we have body
that we can finally look at.
Let's make the" --
>> Daina Ramey Berry:
Great question.
Yeah, great question.
So I'll respond to that based
on the records that I covered.
Because I was studying the medical
records, I was looking at doctors
and even students that were
training that were working
on their medical degrees
in the 19th century.
And one of the students wrote
in his journal that he was happy
because it was time for the
dissections and there's a time
of the year where they
do the dissections
in the winter and the spring.
And he said, "I was happy to do this
and we had our first negro cadaver."
And he said, "And I was so
surprised when we cut it open
that the inside looked the same."
The inside looked the same as
the white cadavers, you know?
So this is on the eve
of racial science.
You know? A lot of what I'm writing
about happens before the American
Medical Association was founded.
So it's before the regulation,
it's before cremation,
it's before formaldehyde and some
of the preservation chemicals
that were being used.
Some of these physicians that
were training the students,
one of them had nightmares
about his body being tampered.
And he was one of the first
cases of cremation in US history.
So he made sure that
his body was cremated
because he didn't want that.
But then there's others, there
are a few physicians at Harvard
who wanted their bodies and their
skeletons to be fully articulated
and on display so students
could study them.
So it's a tough balance because this
is also advancing American medicine,
you know?
And there's that.
But then there's also
the exploitive part of it
that we can't really ignore.
So those are some of the things.
They also measured Morton --
Samuel Morton was part of a larger
trade in skulls in particular.
And Favin [assumed spelling] wrote
about this in The Skull Trade.
And they would measure the brains
because they were trying to decide,
like, were black brains smaller or
larger, what's the cranial capacity?
So there was a lot of that and
there was conversation about that.
But often I would find in these
records they would say whether the
cadaver was negro or not.
It would often say -- it would use
the word negro or negro skeleton.
There was one where they were
talking about a skeleton, they said,
oh, this skeleton when
it was fully macerated,
when they cleaned off all the
skin and the ligament and tendons,
they got it all fully
articulated on the stand,
they said the bones
washed up so white.
And this was a negro skeleton.
And they said when he was
alive he stood six feet five.
I remember when I saw that, that's
all I had on this particular case.
But I was thinking did they know
that because they measured him
when he was laying down or is
this something they actually knew?
Like, I have no idea.
But I was, like, they talked
about how stood six foot five,
was it just because it
was the height or not?
And they talked about how they were
surprised that the bones could wash
up that white coming
from a negro cadaver.
So those are the only
examples that I can think
of off the top of my head.
Other questions?
>> Thank you so much, Dr. Berry
for this riveting lecture.
I also am intrigued and disturbed
by your discussion
of the cadaver trade.
And I'm curious whether either
the resurrection men or the kin
of the dead commented at all,
given your earlier discussion
about soul value and the stress that
the enslaved and freed black men
and women placed on the
immortality of the soul regardless
of what happened to the body,
whether the resurrection men
or the kin of the dead commented
on perhaps the immateriality
in some sense of what
was done to the cadavers,
given the life of the souls.
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Right.
Good question.
So in terms of the actual -- like,
Chris Baker, Grandison Harris,
the actual resurrection men that I
write about, that's what I'm working
on now, is to try to find what they
-- you know, their own testimonies.
I've just found them -- I
found them in records books,
but I haven't found stuff
written and produced by them.
I found a few quotes
from newspaper articles.
Like, one of the schools,
there was a school play.
They did a Christmas ceremony.
And they talked to Chris on stage.
So I have some, like,
voice from him.
They said that he was very
comfortable with bodies.
And I think that for him
-- and I don't know this;
I'll hopefully learn this as
I'm working on the next book --
that there's a separation.
I'm hoping or I think that he might
believe that there's a separation
from the spirit, the soul leaves
the body when it departs this world.
And I think there were some
people that believed that so
that they could stomach
this if they knew about it.
I mean, there was one slave
narrative that I found
by Charlie Grant who was
told to go exhume the body
of a two-year-old infant and
bring it to his enslaver.
And his enslaver was then -- as
Charlie says, "He's going to send it
to Virginia to a doctor and
they're going to cut it up."
So there's an understanding from
some enslaved people, you know,
even in the 20th century
that are talking about that.
There's also newspaper
advertisements of stories
where they talk about
people being afraid
to see Chris Baker on the street.
You know, watch out,
he might snatch you.
So there was this sort of lore
among the free black community
to watch out for him.
But I don't have a sense yet of
what he felt or what he thought.
I don't know about his spiritual
belief system, but people say
that he and Grandison
Harris were really good.
Like, there was a newspaper
article that talked about Harris
and he could break open
a casket and get the body
out within a few minutes.
And they just said he
was good at his craft.
You know, it's kind
of a creepy craft,
but they said he was
very good at what he did.
And there were other body
snatchers that were Irish
out in the Baltimore area.
They were Irish, they were
not all African-American.
Sometimes -- and they worked as part
of a trading system where they had,
like, middlemen just like we
see with the slave trades.
And so it's a very elaborate system
that we're still trying
to find out more about.
Thank you.
>> Thank you for this talk.
Your idea about a soul
value is really provocative.
And I think it's something we'll
talk about as historians for,
you know, the next
few decades to come.
But it seems like having
an individual recognition
of one's own soul value is a
resistive act in and of itself
as your powerful example
with the suicide showed.
And so I'm wondering how this
sort of played out day-to-day
and what were the consequences
of an individual recognizing his
or her own soul value
or spiritual value?
Because it seems like, you know,
if a slave holder notices this,
there are very real
tangible consequences.
What measures did enslaved
people have to take
to conceal this recognition?
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Right.
I think it's great.
I'm actually -- I've been working
on an article on soul value just
to tease it out more than
what I do in the book,
and I've been doing the
research for a couple months now.
And just tracing, like, just
Frederick Douglass is one example.
You're not going to see them
call soul value, you know,
I'm not seeing that there.
But he's talking about what I
would describe it, there was times
where he felt like he couldn't take
anymore and he was going to give up.
And he describes this feeling
in the core of his soul.
He says it's like a flame
that's going to go out.
It's almost done.
He said than something came
over him and it rose again,
he was able to stand up and move
through that painful experience
whether it was a beating,
a whipping, a sale,
or what have you.
And so I'm trying now to look at
how people went in and out of this.
Because I do think that some of
them struggled and some of them went
through periods where
they were very low
and they may not valued
themselves much.
They may have felt like
they wanted to give up.
And then there was something else
that kind of kept them going.
And Douglass describes
it as a flame.
And I think that's a really great
analogy and a way to think about it.
It's something that almost --
for me it's got a dual purpose
because a flame burns, you know?
So you think about the heat
and the power of that, of fire,
and you also think of the fact
that a wind can either take
it out or make it stronger.
And so that's one place.
So I think it also is expressed
through day-to-day resistance,
but then also having to measure when
to scale back so that your owner
or your enslaver doesn't see that
you have this will that's different.
And I think a lot of enslavers
recognized enslaved people
that had strong wills, and
they would try to do all kinds
of things to combat that.
So slavery is a system, I always
say, of negotiation, you know?
And sometimes literacy, writing
yourself a pass, you know,
getting away, finding a way to
escape slavery might have been
that one person's way of
expressing soul value.
And I don't know that
I'm committed to saying
that soul value is
all based on, like,
a Christian belief system, you know?
I think that there's some that
are African belief systems
that would fall along this,
and it may even be people
that don't believe in a
higher power, but they believe
in something about
will and survival.
And so I do see that, but that's
something that I'm sort of trying
to tease out a little bit.
I hope that answers your question.
Okay, good.
>> Thank you for your talk.
This was amazing.
And you kind of just touched on a
little bit what my question was,
was this idea of soul or spiritual
value, did you see it more fleshed
out in the enslaved
who were Christian?
I mean, you talked about Isaac
met with his minister and how --
you know, if they both
believed in the same god.
So I'm just curious,
did that come up?
How did that develop?
And I liked the fact that
you mentioned that those
who didn't believe in a higher
power still believed in themselves
and also the culture they
came from, from Africa.
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Yeah,
it's easier to see it with those
that were Christian because they'll
talk about it because they believe
that there's something
above them that governs,
like a higher being, a god.
But even people with African
religious belief systems believe
in ancestor gods and other people
that have influence on their lives,
even people that came before them
that they may have never met.
And so there's that influence there.
But I think for me, I saw a lot of
soul value in those that ran away
and I always say to
people it doesn't mean
that most enslaved people
escaped -- successfully escaped --
it just that the records
that survived
because abolitionists wrote
them, wrote about these stories
in newspapers or I've used William
Still's Underground Railroad
and found evidence
of soul value there.
Even in the published
narratives from 1825 all the way
through 1870's, the published
primary narratives, there's evidence
of soul value woven all throughout.
Some of them recognize
god as a Christian being
and recognize their soul and
their spirit as something
that lives beyond this here and
now in this space that they're in.
And there's others that did
not necessarily say that
or mention a Christian god but
still believed in something
about themselves, that there's
got to be a better place.
And for some, a better place
was Africa or parts of Africa.
For some a better place was to be on
the other side of the here and now,
whatever that is for them.
And so I'm sort of working through
how I want to describe that.
But here I use evidence
of where they're talking
about these pulls inside them to
know that they're not the commodity
or that value, that dollar
value that's on their bodies,
to know that that's not who they are
and that there's something
beyond that, that there's someone
that encompasses much
more than that.
Thank you.
>> We have time for
one more question.
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Okay.
>> What wonderful talk, thank you.
One of the most complicated families
in American history's is Thomas
Jefferson's, patron of this library
and buildings named after him.
And his slaves in many
cases are his children.
He's also a math guy and he
knows values of object --
have you looked into his papers
and does he go into this?
>> Daina Ramey Berry: Yes, I have.
And actually, I want to read
you a quote that I use here.
I looked at his work for
a while and I was trying
to decide how deep I wanted to go.
I have some of the values of
his enslaved people in the book,
but they're part of the dataset.
But what I did with Jefferson
here, just at the beginning
of the introduction I have a quote
from Benjamin Banneker who writes
to Thomas Jefferson in
August 19th of 1791.
He says, "We are a race of
beings who have long labored
under the abuse and
censor of the world.
We have long been looked
upon with an eye of contempt
and that we have long been
considered rather brutish than human
and scarcely capable
of mental endowments."
so he's trying to look at him and
say let's not just make us a number.
We're human beings, we've
helped build this country.
So I didn't go into too much
detail about him there in the book,
but I do have the figures in there.
There was something else
I was trying to think
of I wanted to say about Jefferson.
It's escaped me.
Yeah, sorry.
But thank you.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.